liberal Mayors making excuses for the
Mayhem playing out in their cities
thousands of teens rioting at a top
tourist spot in New York City after an
online influencer promised them free
PlayStation 5S agitators shutting down
traffic smashing the windshields of cars
others throwing smoke bombs and
fireworks mayor Eric Adams taking some
heat after appearing to give the young
people involved a pass
we're further looking into where there's
some even outside agitators you don't
come to get free game boys and bring
smoke bombs and bring m80s and bring
other disruptive items and so we believe
there was some outside influences that
may have attempted to aggravate this
situation the scene in New York was
eerily similar to the Looting of a gas
station in Chicago by a mob of teens but
the city's Democratic mayor Brandon
Johnson also seemed willing to make
excuses
talking about mob actions I didn't say
that these large gatherings
these large Gatherings just hold on a
second y'all I promise you we have time
to talk it's important that we speak of
these Dynamics in an appropriate way
this is not to obfuscate what is
actually taking place I mean to refer to
children as like Baby Al Capone's is not
appropriate
crime rages out of control people are
forced to take matters into their own
hands police say they are investigating
a wild incident involving two 7-Eleven
employees who thwarted a robbery and one
of whom beat the thief with a stick and
you saw that story here on Fox all right
Greg
um blaming outside agitators when
thousands of young people showed up
within minutes seems a little
far-fetched yeah well first if they
charge those 7-Eleven dudes with
anything it's being awesome all right uh
uh and and and if they do get charged
there's the legal GoFundMe page will be
completely out of this world they should
be getting a key to the city if anything
the guy made it clear in that robbery
that he had a weapon he may not have had
a weapon but he made it clear that he
had one that he apparently had
threatened them the week before yeah
yeah so it's like it's it's sad that
these people are being investigated
um in terms of this these large
Gatherings
um generally when you see a group you
see oh my God it's a group of black kids
that's what you see and then the neck
what would that sound like to when
somebody says oh look at all these black
kids generally it's a liberal because
the second step is they make excuses for
the group oh it's from somewhere else oh
it's because of parenting
um given the circumstances this is the
behavior one would expect from a group
of black teens who is the racist in that
it's them it's the liberals who
constantly make excuses for large groups
of kids creating problems whether it's
looting whether it's this stuff I don't
even you know I don't know I don't know
who this guy is all I know is we have to
start dealing with people not as groups
but as individuals right January 6 that
was a mob some people were good some
people were nuts in this case I'm sure
there's good kids in there there's bad
kids in there we have to start dealing
people dealing with people on individual
merits rather than looking at them as a
group because the moment you look at a
group you make the excuses for the group
and I think that's what you're seeing
with mayor Adams and the other Mayors is
they see a group and they make excuses
why don't you talk about the individuals
then you can't
uh listen to the chief of police and the
New York City as well as the mayor on
some of what Greg is just talking about
watch here
the power of social media and I spoke
about it earlier the power of social
media the danger of social media we went
from 300 kids to a couple of thousand
kids in minutes our children cannot be
raised by social media
our children cannot get their values
their beliefs from social media and
other outside entities our children are
being inundated by influencers by those
who consider themselves to be credible
Messengers
Harold I had not heard of this uh
influencer either costs and not but
apparently a lot of people had and he
maybe he had good intentions of giving
out some of these PlayStation fives but
he did say you know we expect to get a
little crazy in the next few days
leading up to this
well I hope everybody had a good weekend
I do thank you first
um I give mayor Adams a lot of credit uh
and I've been critical of him when I
think he deserved to be criticized but
this is a different little bit here
um when Daniel Penny on a subway uh
defended himself and defended those
around him and we'll have a trial to
determine whether or not I happen to
think that he's more in the right than
wrong
um mayor Adams came on and defended the
police because there were those who said
that the police didn't show up for 20 or
30 minutes he said no it's not true it
was eight minutes you know he was able
to discover that they actually did an
investigation so I think give them give
them some room and space here to
understand if indeed these were
agitators from the outside 300 kids to a
few thousand they probably need to
examine their own protocols the police
to figure out how they can respond more
quickly to these kinds of things and
more effectively two the social media
piece is is very very serious and
obviously related to the first part and
I hope uh that we're able as a society
come to grips with that we're not going
to come to aggressive with that with
this particular issue here but it
certainly was a part of what happened
and finally I would say that to both the
Mayors mayor Adams and I separate
different differentiate between he and
the mayor of Chicago the mayor of
Chicago has his hands full and I I don't
agree with him necessarily all the
things that he was saying but I I remind
anybody in elected office
one of my best friends reminded me last
night he said you know either you go
after crime or crime will come after you
and we have to have short-term and
long-term solutions for the short term
is you got to arrest people you got to
prosecute people uh you got to put
people in jail who deserve to be in jail
you got to end this cashless bill but we
also be short-sighted to not think about
the longer term things we have to do as
well but until we arrest those who
should be arrested it's going to be
harder to make the case and build build
a consensus around some of the longer
term solutions to to these problems
Jesse I love your tie a way to represent
thank you yeah these are foxes
thank you um I'm curious what you think
about this for so many reasons because
you are a very interesting person but I
I'm just thinking about on the maybe on
the parenting front or on the legal
front this happened within minutes so I
think when he asked where are the
parents or someone says where are the
parents well the parents are working
and it's usually a single parent so I
don't know how they can keep tabs on it
yeah they can't uh but on the legal
front I guess Donald Trump now has a
great defense January 6 was just a large
Gathering yes
find people in this crowd
some of them were fine people
how about this remember when Trump said
that you know there were some outside
agitators at January 6 and he wasn't
allowed to say that now it's definitely
mostly these outside agitators because
he said this you don't come to get free
game boys and bring smoke bombs
you don't by the way he's free means
stolen
I don't know I don't know
you say come down to the park to get
free game boys why wouldn't I bring a
smoke bomb is that out of the question
that I pick one up on the way out the
door it's amazing they don't have Intel
to know these things they're
metastasizing in real time like they
they do this on political rallies they
did the Arab Spring caught them uh
caught them you know flat-footed but we
can't with all the money that we're
spending in New York City we can't have
someone online to monitor these things
all of a sudden thousands of people are
in Midtown no one knows why and then the
police show up late and get pelted
there is a pattern in Greg's right of
downplaying urban violence you know I
think so so what's a little bit of our
sin they have insurance they can cover
it you know it's the summer of love baby
people are smashing and grabbing because
they're hungry you know but you know we
got to go after the real violence and
those are the people raising their
voices at school board meetings those
are the radical Catholics because that
fits into this political narrative is
that it's the populists that are causing
all the violence in the country that's
what the FBI is focused on that's what
law enforcement is targeting because
anything that goes outside of that that
blacks are the victims whites are the
oppressors anything that goes outside of
that you're either censored or called
racist now
I don't like this guy whatever his name
is Czech Savant
he doxed Johnny my assistant oh how dare
he Johnny invited him on the show on
Friday at 8. and put his number in and
the guy blasted Johnny's number to
everybody that he follows Johnny has
been getting phone calls text messages
face times all weekend and and Johnny is
the victim here he owes him a
PlayStation
[Laughter]
um one thing Katie is sanat walked away
with uh an appearance ticket walked free
that'll show him um he did not get
enough uh permit to hold the large
Gathering and the NYPD said they 65
people were arrested 30 of them
juveniles but I don't know how the
police are supposed to keep up with who
is an influencer and who's not like I
understand that they could get Intel but
all of a sudden like you could be an
overnight sensation like Johnny I do
give the mayor credit for saying the
parents need to be involved here I mean
the lack of consequences whether it's
from your parents at home a parent at
home or the law enforcement justice
system is a real problem and leads to
stuff like this and we can't even play
some of the footage that was actually at
this Gathering because of the language
that was being used against the police
in addition to the violent Behavior
towards the police and the mob that
ensued injuring bystanders so that's a
cultural problem that's going to have to
be solved there's a problem with
fatherlessness in a lot of homes across
the country that leads to this behavior
and for these young people it's sad for
them because they're on video chanting
these horrible things to the police and
if they ever want to make something of
themselves that doesn't reflect well on
them on the 7-Eleven story
you know we keep seeing things like this
where people defend themselves against
repeat criminals who say they're going
to come into your store and shoot you
this guy who left after stealing who got
beat up by the store owners after coming
in twice is lucky he didn't get shot
he's in a state like California we're
not allowed to defend yourself he's
lucky the consequences weren't worse for
him but just as delayed as Justice
denied and there have no but no arrests
in this case for these guys who are just
trying to earn a living in California
like where's 7-Eleven corporate like are
they going to defend these guys who work
really hard to have policies probably
just let them steal the stuff and walk
away right they steal the microwave
ovens why why do you want them to do
that because they're have you seen us
the interior of a 7-Eleven actually you
know what I have not no
but I will check one out this weekend I
wonder Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now